5 25 on your friday morning so after a
week of musical day camping girls rock
vegas took the stage at the delta
academy in north las vegas last friday
we start at the end
the friday evening showcase concert
where 32 young women who may have never
met or played an instrument pull off
what's apparently not mission impossible
executive director heather rampton says
the non-profit girls rock vegas was
formed in 2009 to empower young women
from 9 to 17 through music creation and
performance
after unloading a truckload of
instruments and equipment the staff of
16 volunteers methodically went through
five days of introducing the campers to
guitars basses and drums
learning the basics of chords and
songwriting
they formed six different bands and got
down to business
[Music]
all right so those girls named their
band the creature fourth removed
it was the 14th annual girls rock vegas
camp part of an international group that
puts on more than 100 camps on six
continents rock on girls if you know
something that's cool that's cool let us
know cool at school under the community
tab on our website or just email us cool
at school at eightnewsnow.com
that was awesome
you had never played an instrument
before some of them may have but a lot
of them had never wow they don't read
music they don't write music but after
five days that's incredible that's one
of the good things about punk music or
rock music if you learn three chords it
can scream you're locked and loaded
you're good to go absolutely and they
were into it yeah for sure there were
some of them that were a little shy and
some of the drumming was not quite where
you wanted to be well after five days i
mean yeah well if you've never done it
before it was incredible yeah
yeah i love that stuff